-You have a great
fan base.
BTS Army is fantastic.
I have questions
from your fans.
"Can you ask BTS,
when they make a song,
what comes first --
the melody or the lyrics?"
-First...
-Beats.
-Yeah.
-The track.
-The beat.
-A track.
-Track.
-The instrumentals.
-Really?
-Yeah. It always comes first.
-Melody or song --
melody or rap.
-So, first the track.
-Yeah.
-Then, you write the lyrics,
and figure it out?
"Can you please ask
R.M. and Jimin
about the black bean
noodle incident?"
What is the black bean
noodle incident?
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Speaking Korean ]
-I had a stomachache, so, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-How long did you go away?
-I don't know.
Like, three or four minutes.
-That's not that long.
it's like --
You know, I was like,
"Um, give me noodles
as fast as you can."
And you know, it's just --
-It was so fast.
-Yeah.
-Swallowed it, and--
-Boom.
-Someone asked, "What do you
particularly look forward to
when doing a concert?"
-[ Speaking Korean ]
Is there any audience
that you want to grab
that you haven't got
the opportunity to meet yet?
-John Cena.
-John Cena?
-We want to see him.
-He's a big fan of us.
-He's the best.
-And we're the big fan --
yeah, it's like --
-Really?
-Mutually, of course.
-He likes J-Hope.
-Yeah, he loves J-Hope.
-John Cena.
-Yeah, we were always watching,
like, WWE, like, when we were,
like, you know,
like, 13, like, 15.
-John Cena!
-[ Vocalizing WWE music ]
[ All vocalize WWE music ]
-Yeah.
-Alright, I'm gonna get you
hooked up with John Cena.
-Oh, please.
-I'm gonna make sure
it happens.
Alright, this one says, "To
people who don't know you yet,
what do you want them
to know about BTS?"
-Turn on the YouTube,
search "BTS Jimmy Fallon."
-Yes.
-Watch the show.
And then, you'll be
in our Army, maybe.
-Yes.
-So, you're performing later.
Is there something you do
before every performance?
Can you show me?
-You want to do it together?
-I'll do it with you.
-Okay.
-Come here.
-So...
We go down.
We don't go up.
So, we'll go down.
And when I say...
[ Speaks Korean ]
And you guys say...
-[ Speaking Korean ]
[ Speaking Korean ]
-[ Speaks Korean ]
-You say -- [ speaks Korean ]
-Yeah.
-So, when I say...
[ speaks Korean ]
you say...[ speaks Korean ]
Okay, and we go down.
[ Speaks Korean ]
-[ Speaking Korean ]
-Yeah!
-Oh, come on.
More BTS when we come back,
everybody!
Yo! New York City!
-Yeah!
♪♪
-Hi, "Tonight Show" buddies.
What's up?
This is Tina Fey.
I'm heading into the subway.
Heading to
the Uptown 1.
Ha ha. Now, you have to clear
that Billy Joel song.
I have been taking
the New York subway
since I first moved here
in 1997.
I remember when I first started
on "Weekend Update,"
and I was like, "Wow, people are
probably going to freak out
when they see me on the subway,
because I'm kind of on TV now."
I was, like,
looking around the car,
waiting for someone
to recognize me.
Guess what?
No one cares.
No one cared then,
and no one cares now.
And that's why I love
New York.
They don't care who's on TV,
who's not on TV.
Everyone's a star.
It's New York City.
No one cares.